When it comes to making a movie, cooperation
is key.
But anyone who's ever had an annoying coworker
knows that sometimes, you just can't get along
with that jerk you're stuck with.
Considering how poorly Sex & the City 2 was
received, it's a little surprising there were
any expectations for a third installment,
but star Sarah Jessica Parker said she was
"disappointed" in September 2017 upon the
announcement that Sex & the City 3 wouldn't
move forward.
Unnamed sources told People that this was
Kim Cattrall's doing, claiming that the star
was making "outrageous demands" in order to
agree to appear in the third film.
Cattrall, however, denied the claims, telling
Piers Morgan in 2017:
"I never asked for any money.
I never asked for any projects.
I'm, ya know, to be thought of as some kind
of diva is absolutely ridiculous."
The New York Post's Paula Froelich wrote an
article blaming Parker and the other co-stars
for mistreating Cattrall from the beginning
of the HBO series, isolating her early on
because they were intimidated and jealous
of arguably the show's only genuine movie
star.
After the death of Cattrall's brother in 2018,
Parker expressed sympathy during a red-carpet
interview.
Cattrall responded on Instagram, writing:
"Your continuous reaching out is a painful
reminder of how cruel you really were then
and now…You are not my friend.
So I'm writing to tell you one last time to
stop exploiting our tragedy in order to restore
your 'nice girl' persona."
She ended the post with a link to Froelich's
story.
In 1992, Penny Marshall directed A League
of Their Own, about the short life of the
first professional all-female baseball league.
Well, wouldn't you know it: As memorable as
Geena Davis was in the film's lead, she wasn't
the original pick for Dottie Hinson.
That honor went to Debra Winger, who quit
the role two weeks before filming.
"You had a little bit of a reputation of going
head to head with your co-stars and kind of
mixing up with them."
"Wow, this is just going so bad for me."
"No it's going great!"
Winger, who'd already had a reputation for
not getting along with other cast members,
apparently had a problem with Madonna, who
both appeared in the film and provided its
theme song, "This Used to Be My Playground."
League producer Elliot Abbott told the Baltimore
Sun that Winger worried that her presence
would "cause a circus atmosphere."
It would be interesting to see how Winger's
career trajectory might have changed if she'd
put up with Madonna's presence.
In the years since, she's so thoroughly disappeared
from the limelight that it inspired Rosanna
Arquette to make the 2002 documentary Searching
for Debra Winger.
We'll probably never know exactly what Bill
Murray said on the set of 2000's Charlie's
Angels that angered Lucy Liu to the point
that he was replaced by the late Bernie Mac
in its sequel, Charlie's Angels: Full Throttle.
But the basic gist is that while filming a
scene Murray said something questioning Liu's
acting talent, and Liu responded by throwing
punches at him until the crew pulled them
apart.
"Well, I'm not surprised because I had a real
long talk with a squirrel one time, longer
than I can talk to most humans."
In some versions, Murray simply said, "You
can't act."
MTV offers an account that has Murray pointing
to Drew Barrymore, Cameron Diaz, and finally
Lucy Liu in succession and saying:
"I get why you're here.
And you've got talent.
But what in the hell are you doing here?
You can't act."
Whatever was said, Murray and Liu reportedly
didn't get along after the incident, leading
Murray to turn down an appearance in number
two.
OK, so let's get one thing straight: Christian
Bale didn't force Ewan McGregor to quit 2000's
American Psycho.
They were never castmates to begin with!
What they were, however, were competitors.
That's right: Bale pretty much strong-armed
the Star Wars actor until he yanked his hat
right back out of the ring.
While good ol' Leonardo DiCaprio was initially
attached to the project, he eventually bowed
out, and Bale was determined to land the role.
He even refused other roles for nine months
in order to keep his schedule open, even though
the studio was still looking for a leading
man elsewhere!
"One part of me wants to take her out, and
talk to her."
"And what'd the other part of him think?"
"What her head would look like on a stick."
Eventually, execs turned to Ewan McGregor,
but he inexplicably gave it a pass.
When GQ asked Bale if he could confirm rumors
that it was him who convinced McGregor to
say no, he responded:
"Absolutely.
I phoned a few people and let them know my
commitment, let me tell you!
I called them all and told them it was my
role.
Don't touch.
Step away.
Or if you're not going to step away, understand
what you're up against."
"I'm a pretty, uhh…
I mean I guess I'm a pretty sick guy."
Which means, from a certain point of view,
you could say Batman used a Jedi mind trick
on Obi-Wan Kenobi.
And that's pretty cool.